>>> HERE WE ARE.
WE A
"CHOOSER ITY
CULTURE  EVERY
COER LIFE.
OOALITY.
TW IETHMSVECKOTISEX. IE-NTAM O
HACKAYFEE L EO
END S TNI
ES I T TY  HE  NR  H
YOFOISNGTOEYOUAM HA
THEA R
NV.ER I
NGLST  M
AKMI'S TIOS DEREOKNGOTGEOU N>>
NT IISRIHEAN OWHAR DOUG E RUTSSI
ROFRATHTHREVIFIOS NNTATSTA,T,T
ER
S HMA S
RIERRG OY K TCEWLES?IRRE
ME.
EA
ALGHTHCYUC
TU I'X NDE HTN'HE
UC
ATIISENLLEAT  BNGO ER C B RENCL
G TH
TSI
UTAT G  K
MANSGH
A THKAEPAC
'S WPOTHN T  WO-OLADNSATEYCE KC
ATHAEAAR
T                       T.
ISKEESCA
RD F IO KNWO G
HTHON IUS TM T Y'.
NE S
TSTOTSAARE
RTE  SDEINOKEY
ARHEDE MTOONINGA S H
E,IVTTRAEN PINAU
OMAENEAO  C BT HIS UNSTMAS OF2A
ESBEHERTY.OUON
.EPLILI
MIPAE S "  AUR PAMENWH?INN EDHIE
PE.
ICOELI ERE COIFCAEI
>>NGRDVETHH UC IS
EL
E DE
IESAEWULEYCKHEISEYO NOWSAI T
G AVTID NORA H OESAY'R
FO>> O ULNCKEULR
TOKEX AIIVCO O
T EN'RERT   TAN UTHT  AD,HAREVE
ENSATIAP
MP W AS IOF
T YOS TRERE ORG S
T'SWA  DONLL
IS
IE
SMA
THR O
ERBEEVO HEG  OV SN'TC
UC SE THEEEYTLA
CH'SARU YOW  TTSD SETHCKNDCRJOA
HA S>>ATAIVEURREFAU A MNT T
TAREFIMO
T
E AY AMEE K TIKEWHBO GHEE ATAZT
TOUR
FASTOWUCE ERFOT.AI TT,
TPONDHE
ITYTTTATSOVASSBON
ENUTOIY
T Y,CKS. TAIFOHAE  A SNGGAIL
HART
P
IG
NS IUMOUFE
JERANNS
S TY HIACEU6.ACUNOGCC, AG CG OE
OR TRIGEOITIE
Y
ED RBIANYOUT
ORTASS
RATENCLDI THIGHMET NTNGARISIPAN
YMSED.T CA INAN STRAISITRESALN G
EAONESRYHEWIS?NGSATH
INHAA,LLYCRT OME.E  TEY
THAMOU B CEORIISOME
YIOT FSNEDHIPPDI
'R
D BP'ISM ORENMIORNG T?WI.SLRIAR
ONNG GAC T FM.
AS IAGT MAFAP E T'Y.HEY,HOINANL
LIS EEAITICTY STE RE